there's a lot to unpack if i'm going to
go i'm going to eat the whole bowl i'm
also going to get an appetizer like i'm
going to enjoy myself my scale has not
gone down at all well this morning i
woke up and i literally felt like i just
like had a high feel so good are you
calling me fat we are going to our
favorite restaurant in tampa to have my
treat
trying to eat good if i'm gonna cheat
every single day i need you guys
i need you guys to hold me accountable
what are you wearing my pajamas i'm
tired i don't want to do this hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's
[Music]
kitchen today we'll be continuing our
series reviewing jaclyn hill's weight
loss series on her channel but first let
me tell you my sponsor natural delights
module dates i admittedly have a super
sweet tooth as do my boys so apparently
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
one of our favorite pantry staples
around here are natural delights medjool
dates we love their chewy texture for
snacking but they're also so amazing at
adding natural sweetness fiber and
potassium to both sweet and savory
recipes and you guys already know that
if you frequent the abby's kitchen blog
or have my book the mindful glow
cookbook i basically put them in
everything now we've always bought
natural delights medjool dates brand
because honestly their flavor and
texture is just unmatched they're grown
in low humidity with high heat and
plentiful water and are made without any
additives or pesticides it's literally
all the work of the warm sun so you can
find medjool dates in the fresh produce
section of the grocery store year round
since they are actually a fresh fruit
and if you want to try out medjool dates
yourself check out the link in my bio to
learn more now before we get into it you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a big trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also if you
are new here please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that bell
so that you never miss out on a video
and also don't forget to follow me on
some of my other social media platforms
as well like instagram and tick tock at
abby's kitchen now if you haven't
checked out the other videos that i
reviewed in this series you can watch
them right here but just in case you
need a quick little recap we've been
following along on jacqueline hill's
weight loss journey that she began
documenting in september 2021. now at
the time of filming this video i'm
caught up to episode 8 of jaclyn's
journey after reacting to episode one
and three in its entirety now today i'm
going to be offering some overarching
themes from the episodes since then and
i'm going to share my thoughts on what i
think may be helping to support jaclyn's
journey and some areas that i think may
still be a bit of a challenge and worth
addressing so let's start with the good
because i want to take a moment here to
offer jacqueline all of my support
kindness and compassion for a moment
because i think that beginning any
transformation on the internet isn't
easy and actually in one video she even
talks about how unkind people on the
internet have been when she eats
something that's not on her plan so i
just want to say i see you jacqueline
and i do think that your journey is
selling that probably a lot of people
can relate to it is not gonna be a
straight line like so many before and
after photo transformation testimonials
make it seem it's gonna be messy it's
gonna be bumpy and there's going to need
to be a lot of work done to figure out
what works uniquely for you one thing i
do love seeing is jaclyn starting to
find nutritious meals that she enjoys
and that make her feel good as this
journey moves along jaclyn talks about
how much easier the eating piece is
getting and she's finding nutritious
meals that she actually enjoys that
aren't completely devoid of flavor
balance or fun let's take a quick look
whenever i've had like the stomach flu
growing up or just anything that has to
do with like stomach issues when my
appetite comes back i always crave a
feta kitty alfredo so instead i made
cauliflower crusted pizza it's not great
for you obviously it's a frozen pizza
but it's still better than making a full
ass like fettuccine alfredo and i use
the trader joe's one and then on my
slices i just add a little balsamic
glaze and basil and it is super super
super yummy it's like it's a new york
pie but it's still super super yummy and
is making me feel happy and better so
i'm making them grilled cheese and then
i will have chicken piccata okay so this
looks incredibly unappetizing right now
but
jordan just made this skillet chicken
piccata
holy crap this is incredible this is a
real improvement from the last episode i
reviewed where she was completely
cutting out carbs and lamenting over how
terrible her bunless burger was there
are definitely times when that i must
cut out all the bad foods mentality
sneaks in in fact she actually says that
herself at one point in the series but
there are moments here where i'm seeing
a little bit more balance than we did in
the past so with time she may be
realizing that allowing herself maybe
some rice with dinner or like a frozen
cauliflower pizza crust with cheese and
her favorite toppings will be much more
sustainable than just allowing herself
flavor free super low calorie super low
carb meals that she truly hates i think
we obviously have a long way to go to
make this a sustainable lifestyle and
not just like a 60-day challenge but it
probably feels safer for her to kind of
stick her toe in the water to test out
the temperature before just diving right
in
now speaking of testing i also really
like that she's starting to collect some
data beyond just the numbers on the
scale to serve as a source of motivation
so we're going to talk about the scale
and weighing behaviors in more detail in
a moment but i am happy to at least hear
her mention some non-weight related
outcomes of her diet like feeling better
or having clear thoughts or energy or
just enjoying her healthy meals a little
bit more so let's take a quick look well
this morning i woke up and i literally
felt like i just like had a high feel so
good i feel so energetic i got out of
bed and i literally felt lighter i feel
so good i feel so clear i feel so
energetic and then i got on the scale
and my weight actually has dropped which
is insane like i was 173 which i have
not seen on the scale in a very very
long time and it just it encourages me
so much so we have another birthday
party our good family friend so it's
gonna be more pizza and more wings so
i'm actually gonna be meal prepping my
own food for the party today because
i've realized that this is a job whether
you want to accept it or not so right
now it is thursday and i have not
cheated on my diet i think that's what
i'm calling it now although i really
don't feel like i'm dieting because i
feel i feel so good you guys i have not
had anything except a potato chip since
last thursday so seven days and i am
feeling so good and honest to god it's
gotten easy jordan made a pasta today
that looked delicious and i genuinely
didn't even want to eat it because i'm
like i feel good right now when i wake
up in the morning i feel lighter i put a
pair of jeans today that i was unable to
get buttoned two weeks ago and i wore
them for hours and i was comfortable i'm
just feeling good and i feel excited my
scale has not gone down at all in the
last couple of days which is super
frustrating over the past two days my
skill has gone up a powder and a half
and i genuinely don't believe it because
i'm feeling better and better every day
my clothes are fitting me better i'm
like my skill is lying to me so i don't
really know i'm not lifting heavy
weights like i'm putting on muscle so
i'm not gaining weight and muscle i
don't know but i'm trying not to focus
on the skill i like that there is at
least some mention of the non-weight
outcomes here because feeling good from
eating more nutritious balanced meals
and moving our body are really outcomes
that we can more reliably count on what
happens on the scale is often somewhat
out of our control so hormones bathroom
habits water retention metabolic
compensatory mechanisms are all designed
to prevent extreme weight loss so these
videos to me really show that weight
loss is not a linear journey
[Music]
it's not always predictable so if we
rely exclusively on that external
feedback from the scale as a motivator
for healthy behavior change it's really
hard to stay on track during the weeks
when the scale doesn't budge collecting
data that hey yeah like i feel really
good when i eat this way and maybe i
have some you know veggies in my meal
regardless of what the scale does keeps
our focus on what we can actually
control having said that i do still see
jaclyn struggling to let go the tight
grip that the scale has over her i can
see it still holds a lot of power to her
and while her words are saying like i
don't care about this this is not
important even in the first video that i
reviewed she's still weighing herself
quite a bit an over dependence on
validation from the scale would be one
of the areas i would recommend we work
on
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
so i've now gone from 183 to 172 i am
looking
so much leaner which is so exciting
i hit 172 on the scale
that's a big deal i've literally been
sitting at 173 for like
10 days my scale has not gone down at
all weighing ourselves multiple times a
week is really setting ourselves up for
a disappointment which i do tend to see
at times in this journey for jaclyn what
often happens here on any diet is that
we lose a significant amount of water
weight at the start which is really
encouraging so we continue doing the
same thing we've been doing but once
your body realizes like whoa
uh this diet is like a long time thing
it starts fighting to hold on to that
weight so it increases our hunger
hormone grayline reduces our satiety
hormone leptin reduces our casual
activity in the day increases our stress
hormone cortisol which stores fat and it
makes our mind obsessed over food and
getting in more calories all day even in
a non-diet context our body weight will
naturally fluctuate daily based on our
food intake water consumption bathroom
habits hormonal fluctuation etc so in
the context of weight loss i recommend
not weighing yourself more than once a
week now my next concern is that i'm
seeing jacqueline adopt like a no pain
no gain mentality that i think is
actually counterproductive to her
long-term success now in the first two
episodes we saw a lot of dragging
ourselves through meals and workouts
that we really didn't like only to set
ourselves up to overeat later on during
a cheat now since then i am starting to
see a little more compromise on some
things at times so that to me is a
really great step towards better
self-awareness and better self-care but
still when the number on the scale
doesn't seem to budge fast enough jaclyn
seems to tighten the reins and engage in
a lot of negative self-talk and rigidity
with regards to forcing herself to do
things she really hates to do let's take
a look the 60 day thing is just out the
window i'm feeling super disappointed in
myself and frustrated with the way i
haven't stuck to this there's always an
excuse to eat bad food what's the point
in trying to eat good if i'm gonna cheat
every single day i was so stressed like
an hour ago i made myself a drink i need
something to take the edge off i'm so
stressed out by today i'm gonna go home
i'm gonna force myself to get on that
damn treadmill and get a workout
what are you wearing
my pajamas i'm tired i don't want to do
that
this is a whole new level you're never
going to wake up and be like oh my god i
can't wait to work out today that's
never going to be your life let's do it
because i love the result i hate my life
but i'm going to work out you did
something that you didn't wanna do
that's so good for you okay there's a
lot to say about this first of all i
understand it's probably really annoying
to see a thin white woman on youtube or
instagram tell you how much they love
salad or love going for a run or love
doing an intense spin class okay
everybody let's take this next hill not
all of us get that runner's high or are
obsessed with green things so i'm not
even going to start on the potentially
patronizing find an exercise you love
because the reality is you might just
not
love any of it however you do need to
find something that you are okay with
you don't need to love it but you need
to be okay with it and to understand
your threshold for when things shift
from tolerating it or thinking it's okay
to hating it and forcing yourself to do
it if you're exercising to change your
body here's the brutal truth exercise
isn't even a super effective weight loss
strategy so if you're stuck unsure of
how to even start liking exercise the
first step is to uncouple the
association of weight loss with exercise
next stop thinking oh if it's not super
hard and i'm not drenched in sweat that
exercise doesn't count no no no no no
god please no no
no
all movement is good movement and if
it's not sustainable there's little to
no point in you doing it in my opinion
if you don't get out of the all or
nothing mentality it is impossible to
even explore activity to find something
that maybe we can like and enjoy and i
worry that a miserable exercise
experience may kind of poison the
experience as a whole and result in
jacqueline calling it quits on all of
the health-promoting behaviors because
she kind of sees them as a packaged deal
so in my opinion the treadmill may
actually be holding her back from
reaching her goals long term next we're
still seeing a lot of this kind of cheat
day last supper mentality around food as
a result of all or nothing thinking
let's take a look i'm like why would i
go there and split a bowl of pasta like
if i'm going to go i'm going to eat the
whole bowl i'm also going to get an
appetizer like i'm going to enjoy myself
so today's cheat day
all the carbs but you're eating healthy
on a cheat day mm-hmm because
meal oh so you're saving up for dinner
absolutely
day two of micah being here jordan made
us what looks to be the yummiest
breakfast ever i got a three different
sopas got a quesadilla jordan is making
something that i can't have
oh i have been eating super super clean
i honest to god like haven't cheated
since micah was here so we're going out
with my brother and sister and some of
our good friends and we're gonna enjoy
yummy yummy yummy food i'm not gonna
hold back i'm gonna live my best uh we
ordered a couple of appetizers and they
were like a four out of ten and i was
like you know what i don't want to spend
my cheat on this so now we are leaving
this place we had appetizers and we are
going to our favorite restaurant in
tampa to have my cheat as i already
mentioned jaclyn's meals on the diet are
definitely looking more balanced and a
little less restrained and i have no
issue with her enjoying any of these
foods including the mac and cheese her
fans like chastised her for but it's
more in the language she uses so
jaclyn's still clearly stuck in this
kind of like on the diet off the diet
seesaw situation so we're seeing a lot
of like i'm saving my calories for a big
cheat or i've been so good this week so
i'm not gonna hold back i'm gonna live
my best life and i think this approach
is going to get stale really fast not
only is it very easy to undo a caloric
deficit in a big cheat night or a big
cheap weekend but it also creates a
cycle that's very hard to break so we
restrict we feel deprived we overeat
when we do allow ourselves to cheat only
to restrict even harder the next day
jacqueline has said that she wants this
diet to be a long-term lifestyle so
allowing herself small food pleasures
daily and finding ways to eat out and
choose more balanced meals more often is
going to be a really valuable weight
management skill to build so i think her
boyfriend jordan is really on to
something here that's splitting the bowl
of pasta or you know having a couple
bites and trying out a new fun recipe
even if it's not on the diet is actually
the key to making this sustainable long
term finally speaking of jordan i think
jaclyn's actually looking for the wrong
kind of support in her journey let's
take a look i need you guys to be hard
on me i need you guys to hold me
accountable i posted that i got like
that larae's mac and cheese on my insta
story and i can't even begin to tell you
the amount of people in my dms right now
telling me this isn't healthy chocolate
you're not going to lose weight eating
stuff like this this is the kind of
toxic behavior that the internet
delivers and it makes me literally want
to like record myself just shoving that
mac and cheese in my face i asked him to
support me and i asked him like you know
if i wanna eat a bowl of pasta or if i
wanna whatever it is please like support
me have my back tell me like you don't
need that it's not good for you then
when he does it i get frustrated and i
feel like are you calling me fat i know
that he's trying to support me but
sometimes it feels like he's
discouraging me this is a big one and i
do hope she takes this one to heart
asking people to shame you into making
healthy choices is only going to force
you to do the opposite like jaclyn said
it herself when fans tell her not to eat
the mac and cheese she wants the damn
mac and cheese even more now this
phenomenon is well documented in the
literature and it's the same reason why
medical professionals friends or other
societal figures telling people to lose
weight doesn't make people lose weight
this shame induced stigma just makes
people avoid the gym avoid the doctor
avoid the dietitian and instead eat less
nutritious food and engage in risky
unhealthy behaviors it doesn't repair
health disparities it reinforces them
and we also know research has shown how
important it is to have a strong social
support system for any lifestyle
interventions so i can tell that
jaclyn's boyfriend jordan is trying to
support her like he seems like such a
lovely guy and also his cooking looks
amazing but jaclyn isn't quite sure what
she wants or needs from him and i can't
make that decision for her because
everyone's communication styles and
needs are different but a lot of folks
find that having their partner partake
in their diet and exercise routine
together can be helpful and also seeing
jordan has some amazing culinary skills
i'm sure he could help make mealtimes
more delicious no matter what's involved
i also would encourage jordan to focus
on just enabling jaclyn to make healthy
choices rather than shaming her or
policing her when she doesn't and it
sounds like he's not doing that but it
sounds also like jaclyn's asking him to
do that so for example maybe helping her
do some more meal prep and helping plan
date nights that are not focused on food
and alcohol or of course also going on
like nightly walks together all of that
can help to support without shaming so
i'm hoping to see where jaclyn really
nets out on this and perhaps she finds
some of these observations and tips
useful for the remainder of her journey
which i expect will be more involved
than any 60-day youtube series will ever
be able to cover and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video don't forget to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with your thoughts and what you'd
like to see me cover next subscribe to
the channel and i will see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]